[تصفيق]
اذا تغطيتنا المباشره متواصله مشاهدينا
لتداعيات الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب سوريا
وتركيا خمسه ايام مرت على وقوع هذه
الكارثه المدمره ورغم تضاؤل فرص العثور
على ناجين بعد كل هذه الايام لا زالت فرق
الانقاذ تواصل جهودها على امل العثور على
احياء تحت الحطاب واليوم اعلنت الحكومه
السوريه مناطق حلب اللاذقيه حماه وادلب
مناطق منكوبه جراء الدمار الواسع وفيما
اكد المرصد السوري ان امل العثور على
ناجينا قد تقلص هذا وحذر برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي من نفادي مخزونه في شمال غرب
سوريا داعيا ايضا الى فتح المزيد من
المعابر الحدوديه من تركيا الى الشمال
السوري حيث يعتمد 90% من السكان على
المساعدات الانسانيه واكد المدير الاقليمي
لبرنامج الاغذيه العالميه في الشرق الاوسط
وشمال افريقيا كورن فليشر ان هناك حاجه
تجديد المخزون
الصمت هنا مختلف ليس كاي صمت حتى انه عرف
بصمت الموت فعلى طريق النجاه ينادي
المنقذون بصوت واحد ثم يصمتون جميعا
وسيله استخدمها المنقذون للعثور على
ناجيين في سوريا وعلى قله الامكانيات ولو
كان الامل ضعيفا بوجود انفاس تحت هذه
الانقاض يحاول عمال البحث بطرق بدائيه
وتقليديه
في ظل تعقيد البحث وصعوبه الوصول وسماع
الناجين تحت اقوام الركام تطورت ادوات
البحث لنجده العالقيين فاعتمد الخبراء على
تقنيات تكنولوجيه تطورت عبر الزمن ومن
ابرزها الفئران والصراصير المزوده
بكاميرات صغيره القادره على الدخول الى
امكنه لا يمكن رؤيتها او حتى سماع اصوات
تطلب استغاثه الافعى الروبوت على شكل
ثعبان يستطيع صعود درجات عاليه والتنقل
عبر المساحات الضيقه تقنيه حديثه يسعى
الباحثون لاستخدامها الطائرات المسيره
بامكانها فصل الاحياء عن الاموات عن طريق
الكشف عن حركه بسيطه للضحايا وحده فايندر
تاتي بحجم حقيبه اليد ترسل موجات دقيقه
منخفضه الطاقه ويمكن ان تكشف الموجات عن
خفيه مثل النبض الخفيف للجلد الذي يكشف عن
دقات القلب
مشعلا مصباحه ينادي مسابقا الزمن اعلى
صوته ينجح في انقاذ عالق من قبضه تلك
الانقاض بشتى الطرق وباي طريقه كانت يحاول
ولا يزال
عصام عبد السلام العربيه
مباشره الى عبد المحسن الحربي منفذ
العربيه من غازي عنتاب عبد المحسن مرحبا
بك معي في هذه التغطيه المباشره لازلت تقف
امام يعني شاحنه ربما المساعدات التي وصلت
وشاحنات المساعدات ايضا التي وصلت ايضا او
في المطار التي وصلت عبر طبعا الطائرات
عفوا عبد المحسن ما الذي يعني اجملته من
معلومات حتى هذه اللحظه عن هذه المساعدات
تفضل
نعم نايف بالفعل هذه هي الشحنه مباشره يتم
تفريغها بالشاحنات في خلف هذه الطائره في
الجزء الاخر في المطار وفي ايضا الجزء
في مقدمه الطائره مباشره يتم تفريغ هذه
الشحنه من المساعدات في الطائره الثالثه
عبر الجسر الجوي السعودي الذي وصلت من هذه
الطائره التي تحمل المساعدات الاضخم حتى
هذه اللحظه
ب104 اطنان من المساعدات الغذائيه
والايوائيه والطبيبيه
وكافه المساعدات الاخرى بالاضافه الى
الملابس الشتويه التي سيتم مباشره تفريغها
عبر هذه الشاحنات الى المناطق المخصصه
للتوزيع وتحديدا هنا في غازي عنتاب وفي
المناطق الاخرى في الجمهوريه التركيه
تحديدا في الجنوب التركي بالاضافه الى جزء
اخر سيذهب الى داخل سوريا وتحديدا في
المناطق المتضرره في الداخل السوري جراء
هذا الزلزال وتم بالفعل
التعهد او التواصل مع ومؤسسات اغاثيه
دوليه بالاضافه الى منظمات دوليه واقليميه
ستوصل هذه المساعدات مباشره للمستفيدين
الى داخل السوري باشراف مباشر من مسؤولين
مركز الملك سلمان كما تحدثوا نايف
بالاضافه الى ذلك ينتظر ان تصل خلال ربما
الساعات القليله القادمه
الطائرتين الرابعه والخامسه
الجسر الجوي السعودي ولكن هذه هاتين
الطائرتين هي مخصصتان لفريق البحث
والانقاذ السعودي
بصحبتها ما يقارب 97 من المتخصصين في
عمليات الانقاذ
وايضا مؤهلين لتعامل مع هذه الظروف
بالاضافه الى عربات ضخمه وتحديدا عن معدات
نتحدث لاستخدامها في عمليه انتشال اما
الاشخاص النا من داخل هذه
الحطام او حطام البيوت التي ندمت او
بالاضافه الى ذلك مساعده السلطات التركيه
في اي جزء من عمليه رفع هذه يعني نحن
نتحدث عن مساعدات اضافيه
وانسانيه مواد غذائيه طبيه وكذلك ايضا
مواد تستخدم في المعتقيله طبعا تستخدم في
ربما ازاله الركام او البحث عن ناجين ايضا
كذلك او ربما حتى ما ينقص يعني المسعفين
او المنقذين في مناطق الانقاذ هل هذا صحيح
نعم بالفعل نايف كما تحدثت مع مسؤوليه
مركز الملك سلمان وكما كنا قبل قليل عند
احد المواقع المتضرره التي يتم رفع
الانقاض منها كان هنالك حديث من قبل
المسؤولين الاتراك المتواجدين في ذلك
الموقع مع مسؤولين مركز الملك سلمان على
الاحتياجات وهم بالفعل مركز الملك سلمان
وفريق الانقاذ بدا بالعمل فعليا في ذلك
الموقع في داخل غازي عن تاب بالاضافه الى
تنسيق لوصول هذه المساعدات بالاضافه الى
وجود ايضا فريق من الخبراء الذين وصلوا
يوم الامس من مركز الملك سلمان لتقييم
الحاجه ومدى ايضا
امكانيه او الحاجه الى مزيد من المساعدات
خصوصا المساعدات المتخصصه الدقيقه التي
يحتاجها الجانب التركي او حتى
من سوريا وتحديدا الجهات الفاعله والعامله
في تلك المناطق التي بدات في الفعل
الاجتماعات مع مركز الملك سلمان لتوفير
اللازم وهو بالفعل بدا بهذه العم قبل
ساعات ومباشره ستنطلق هذه المساعدات الى
داخل ممتاز عبد المحسن في الاجزاء
المتفرقه من تركيا عبد المحسن عن اليه
وطريقه توزيع هذه المساعدات هل هناك خطط
واليات ايضا لتوزيعها هل هو معلوم اماكن
طبعا توزيع هذه المساعدات وكذلك ايضا
التنسيق بين يعني مركز الملك سلمان للغاثه
والاعمال الانسانيه وكذلك مع السلطات
التركيه
نعم نائب بالحقيقه في التنسيق مع بين
هاتين الجهتين مركز الملك سلمان
والسلطات التركيه كان تم الاتفاق بشكل
مبدئي على العمل خلال على الاقل الايام
القليله القادمه في مدينه غازيه عنتاب
فبالتالي المساعدات وايضا تحدث عن فريق
الانقاذ تحديدا سيعمل بشكل مباشر هنا في
غازي عنتاب بالاضافه الى المساعدات
الهوائيه والغذائيه التي ستوجه الى تركيا
ستكون في غازي عنتاب بشكل مباشر لمساعده
كافه المتضررين سواء بشكل مباشر اما كانوا
تحت الانقاذ
والمساعده الجهات الاعلى عمليه انتشالهم
بالاضافه الى المنتضررين بشكل غير مباشر
وهنا نتحدث عن الاشخاص الذين ليس لديهم
ماوى الذين يحتاجون الى الغذاء والدواء
ومخيمات التي تؤويهم على الاقل خلال
الاسابيع القليله القادمه وهذا بحسب ما
السلطات السعوديه حيث قالت بان الدفعه
الاولى من هذه المساعدات ستصل بشكل عاجل
مباشر
لرفع هذه والاستجابه العاجله لهذا لهذه
الكارثه بالاضافه الى فريق تقييم مستمر
سيعمل على تحديد
الاحتياجات الخاصه
وايضا تحديدها من خلال هذا الجسر الجوي
الذي سيغلق اليوم خمسه طائرات من طائراته
التي وصلت وسيستمر بذلك نتحدث عن مجرد
يومين نايف كانوا لك خمس طائرات وتحدث عن
طائرات ضخمه كما هذه الطائره التي تحمل
على 104 اطنان تحدثنا مسؤول سوريا تركي
قبل قليل في المطار قال بان هذه الطائره
تحمل على متنها اطنان كبيره جدا وهم
يحتاجون لساعات حتى تفريغها نثر نظرا
لكميه وحجم هذه المساعدات الكبيره جدا
لذلك سيستغرق الموضوع يعني ربما ساعات
قليله
يتم انزال هذه الشحنات مباشره يعني ياخذك
الى زاويه اخرى عبد المحسن يعني انت كنت
ربما منذ صباح اليوم في مناطق يعني متضرره
بشكل كبير انقاض ايضا كانت موجوده من حولك
محاولات
لاخراج الناجينه ان بقي احد من الناجين
طبعا تحت هذه الكومه من الركام التي
شاهدناها معك منذ خرجت ووصلت الى هناك كيف
هي الاوضاع الصوره كامله في غازي عنتاب
بعد خمسه ايام من هذا الزلزال المدمر عبد
المحسن
الصوره في الحقيقه نايف ماساويه عندما
تسير في الطرقات
تشاهد عدد كبير من الاسر التركيه وحتى
النازحين السوريين متواجدين في الاماكن
العامه في الحدائق في الشوارع في كل
الاماكن العراء هم اما ان كان لديهم خيم
تحصلوا عليها والبعض الاخر ليس لدي خيمه
بل هو موقد للنيران ويتدفا بها في هذا من
الجانب الانساني ومن جانب الاشخاص الذين
لم يجدوا ماوى بجانب ايضا
الطرقات الحياه في غازي عنتاب شبه هادئه
جدا الطرقات يعني لا توجد سيارات كثيره
الكل مشغول في عمليه الانقاذ في عمليه
ايضا ايجاد ماوى له خصوصا الذين فقدوا
منازلهم والاماكن المحيطه بها فبالتالي
الوضع بشكل عام ماساوي جدا هنا في غازي
عنتاب وهي ثالث مدينه متضرره من الزلزال
بالاضافه الى ذلك هذا انعكس على مطالبات
وطلبات المسؤولين الاتراك لزياده تكثيف
هذه المساعدات
الاغاثيه فبالتالي في هذا المطار عندما
تواجدنا نايف شاهدنا الكثير من الطائرات
الكثير من الدول
والمنظمات واللغاتيه والانسانيه وكذلك
الدوليه على سبيل المثال نايف في هذه
الجانب من الجزء من المطار هذا هذا فريق
انقاذ من القوات المسلحه السودانيه وصل
قبل قليل وهو عدد تقريبا خمسين
عامل او شخص متخصص في الانقاذ وصلوا
مباشره الى المطار بجانب الطائره السعوديه
للعمل مباشره وادخال واشاهدهم الان يخرجون
بعض الادوات ربما المساعدات السودانيه في
غازي عنتاب وهم منذ قليل وصلوا
وساعملون ويدخلونا مباشره الى داخل غازي
عنتاب لبدء الاعمال هذا هو الوضع العام في
المطار يعكس الحاله الماساويه في داخل
تركيا الوضع يعني المعاناه كبيره جدا
والسلطات التركيه تقول بانها غير قادره
لوحدها على
الايفاء بكل المتطلبات تريد المساعده وما
تم بالفعل نشاهد عدد كبير من
الجهات المختلفه تعمل بجانب السلطات
التركيه بالاضافه الى الجيل المسؤوله وهي
افاد على تنظيم هذا العمل والدخول مباشره
ومساعده الناس خصوصا الاشخاص الذين يبيتون
في العراق لان الخطوره عليهم اكثر نظرا
للطقس البارد جدا نايف بعد المحسن انا
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على كل هذه المعلومات
والتفاصيل ساعود اليك في يعني ثنايا هذه
التغطيه انجدت معلومات جديده او ان كانت
لديك ايضا حتى صوره جديده عبد المحسن
تنقلها لنا عنتاب حتى الان شكرا جزيلا
لك ونبقى وياكم مشاهدينا في هذه التغطيه
ينضم الينا من ريف حلب الصحفي احمد ابو
لؤي سيد احمد مرحبا بك معي مره اخرى في
هذه التغطيه يعني من الملفت اليوم هو
الحديث حديث برنامج الغذاء العالمي عن ان
مخزون المساعدات الغذائيه يكاد ينفذ في
شمال غرب سوريا نريد ان نعرف كيف هي
الصوره هناك ما هو ايضا حتى مستوى هذه
المواد التي دخلت وكميه هذه المواد التي
دخلت الى الغرب السوري ان كانت لديك
معلومات سيد احمد
نعم بالفعل الان تدخل قوافل اضافيه من اجل
تغطيه جزء من حرفيات الناس المتواجدين في
العراء والذين هجروا بسبب هذا الزلزال
القاتل طبعا
المعلومات الشكر ان هنالك
ستدخل من معبر باب الهوى هو المعبر الرسمي
والمقوى
لادخال اي حاجيات اي مساعدات
كارثيها او فيها يعني الامه الخامس
غالبيه الاحاديث من العائله درج
تصفيه
م من الداخل المنظمات
بكافه مستودعاتها طبعا يعني وضع يتكلم
بالماسات ساتكلم قليلا عن موضوع الدفاع
المدني فرق الدفاع المدني ما زالت حتى
الان
تقوم يعني تقوم باخراج العالقين تحت
الركام في منطقه جنديرس تلقين عزمارين
الاثار حلب الغربي ما زال هنالك المئات من
العائلات العالقه تحت الركام طبعا نسبه
الوفيات اليوم
تعتبر
او ترتفع بسبب الساعات الطويله التي مضت
وما زال هنالك تحت الركام هل هناك تقديرات
لاعداد الضحايا سيد احمد
نعم احصائيات القتله
الدفاع
يعني الصوت يتقطع لم نستطيع سماع الرقم
بالتحديد اذا سمحت ان تعيد لنا الرقم
الدفاع المدني الجرحى
بشكل كلي وصل تعداد ل 418 مبنى
220 مبنى منهم في منطقه واحده هي المنطقه
المنكوبه جنديرس في ريف عفرين شمال
انا فقط يعني انا فقط يعني لان الصوت
يتقطع سيد احمد سعيد الارقام وانت تؤكدها
انت تتحدث عن 1970 قتيلا وتتحدث عنه
سننتقل للابنيه التي دمرت ارتفعت حصيله
الابنيه الى 118 او تجاوزت 418 بناء
دميروا بشكل كلي طبعا في نفس المناطق لكن
الحص اكبر قدرتها المنطقه
عفرين الشمال 220 مبنى حتى الان دمروا
بشكل كلي طبعا هنالك
1300 مبنى دمروا بشكل جزئي اضافه لالاف من
المباني التي تصدعت ومن الطعف عوده
الاهالي للسكن فيها وهي عائله للسقوط طيب
ابقى معي سيد احمد سعودي اليك بعد قليل
نحاول فقط يعني ان نتجاوز هذه المشكله
الفنيه من الماستر وهي تقطع الصوت معنى
ريم ندى ناطقه باسم برنامج الاغذيه
العالمي في الشرق الاوسط سيدي ريم مرحبا
بك معي في هذه النشره يعني الحديث اليوم
عن نفاذ المخزون مخزون الغذاء من مناطق
سوريا الشماليه الشماليه الغربيه كيف هو
الوضع هناك كيف تقيمونه انتم ايضا
هو الوضع طبعا الانساني صعب جدا كما
تتخيلون وكما تشاهدون ولكن المخزون على
وشك انك يعني حضرت المديره الاقليميه
للبرنامج من ان البرنامج الاقليمي برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه الان قد وزع بشمال غربي
سوريا 25 الف حصه غذائيه تكفي عفوا حصص
غذائيه تكفي لاسبوع ل 25 الف شخص في مخازن
برنامج شركاء برنامج الاغذيه العالميه
هناك حصص غذائيه الان تكفي لمئه الف شخص
ولكن هناك حاجه ماسه الى تسهيل عبور
المساعدات الانسانيه الى المناطق المتضرره
في كل سوريا خاصه في الشمال السوري وهي
المناطق الاكثر تدارا برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه لانه يعمل في سوريا
يعني يساعد سته ملايين شخص كل شهر قبل قبل
الكارثه يعني هناك حاجه ماسه الى
فتح كل وسائل الدخول الى شمال سوريا سواء
كانت عن طريق الداخل السوري او كل المعابر
ان انتم انتم كيف كيف توصلون المساعدات
ايضا الغذائيه الى هذه المناطق المتضرره
خصوصا في الشمال السوري والشمال الغربي من
اي معابر انتم دخلتم بهذه المساعدات
المساعدات تصل من الداخل السوري وايضا تصل
عن طريق معبر باب الهواء المعبر الوحيد
الذي يمكن الدخول منه الى الشمال السوري
عن طريق تركيا كان هناك معابر اخرى ولكن
تم غلقها لذلك يعني هناك حاجه ماسه الان
الى فتح كل هذه المعابر وايضا زياده
استيعاب
المنافذ من داخل السوري حتى يستطيع
البرنامج ايصال مساعداته من جميع الجهات
هل تواصلتم مع اي
يعني باحد في سوريا مع نظام السوري مثلا
لمحاوله او طلب تسهيل هذه
المساعدات والدخول هذه المساعدات من
الداخل السوري الى المناطق المتضرره في
الشمال الغربي السوري
هو برنامج الفعل يعمل في سوريا نحن يعني
نحن ننسق مع جميع الاطراف للوصول الى
الاشخاص المتضررين برنامج الاغذيه
العالميه يهدف الوصول الى
كل الاشخاص الذين تضرروا من هذه الازمه
حتى الان وصلنا الى 43,000 شخص منهم
25,000 شخص في مناطق شمال غربي السوريه
ولكن يجب ان نستمر في التوزيع يجب ان يتم
تسهيل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه او ازاله
العقبات اذا كانت موجوده يعني على لسان
المتحدث او المدير الاقليمي للبرنامج في
الشرق الاوسط وشمال افريقيا قال بان هناك
حاجه الى تجديد هذا المخزون سيده ريم
وبالتالي نسال هنا عن كميه هذا المخزون
كيف ايضا ستتم اليه دخولها الى هذه
المناطق المتضرره وهل نتوقعها قريبا تاخذ
مزيدا من الوقت 90% من السكان في هذه
المناطق يعتمدون على مساعداتكم في برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي في الشرق الاوسط
في هذه
ولذلك هناك مخزون لبرنامج الاغذيه
العالميه هناك مخزون يكفي لمئه الف شخص
وجبات
لا تحتاج الى طه تكفي لمده اسبوع وهناك
مخزون يكفي الى يكفي مليون ونصف
شخص ولكنها حصص غذائيه شهريه ولكن تحتاج
الى الطه بالنسبه لدخول المساعدات نحن
نستخدم ممر باب الهوى نحن نستخدم المعابر
في داخل سوريا ولكن بسبب يعني بسبب
الزلزال والدمار الطرقات
مدمره ولذلك هناك بطء لذلك
ندعو الى فتح مزيد من الممرات هذا كان
هناك باب السلام يدخل منه تدخل منه
المساعدات الانسانيه ولكن تم غلق
هناك 14 قافله ايضا حتى مساعدات واغاثه
ايضا دخلت مع معبر باب الهوى وقبل قليل
يعني كنت اسال احد الصحفيين الموجودين في
بالقرب من معبر باب الهوى ذكر بان هذا
المعبر معبر مفتوح تدخل من خلاله ايضا
الشاحنات المساعدات الغازيه والانسانيه
وبالتالي لا يوجد في هذا المعبر اي ضرر
كبير يمنع المساعدات من الدخول عبره فهل
هناك تحديات وعوائق اخرى غير هذا السبب
هي فقط البطء البطء الوصول بسبب الدمار في
المنطقه نحن نتحدث هذه هي المنطقه التي هي
الاقرب لمركز الزلزال لذلك هناك بطء هناك
ايضا
[موسيقى]
تسارع الوصول الى هذه المنطقه مما يبتاء
عمليه الدخول ولكن حتى الان هناك
مساعدات يتم توزيعها يتم توزيعها منذ امس
كما ذكرت ل 25 الف شخص هناك مخزونيا في
100,000 شخص ولكن نحن
نعمل على
انعاش هذا المقصود طيب يعني نحن نتحدث عن
عن مخزون يكفي لمده لمده اسبوع من المفترض
ان تصل مساعداتكم ان يتم تجديد هذا
المخزون قبل انتهاء هذا الاسبوع سيدريم هل
هذا ما افهمه
في غضون الايام القليله
فهو يعني ينفذ المخزون ما الذي سيساعدكم
على تعزيز قدرتكم في الوصول الى الشمال
شمال الغربي في سوريا
ما الذي سيسهل عملكم
وسيوصل هذه المساعدات بشكل عاجل
المعابر تتحدثين عن باب الهوى ومعبر
الراعي وباب السلام
طيب في كل الاحوال انا اشكرك جزيل الشكر
على وجودك معنا وكل هذه الاضاحات
والتفاصيل ريم لدى الناطقه باسم برنامج
الاغذيه العالمي في الشرق الاوسط شكرا
جزيلا لك
من القامشلي ينضم الينا مراسل العربيه
جماعه مرحبا بك معي في هذه النشره جمعه هل
من جديد لديك حول اي احصائيات اي ارقام
حتى هذه اللحظه عمليات الانقاذ كذلك كيف
تسير من حولك
نعم هناك تحديث على ارقام القتلى
ليس سابدا من مناطق النظام
1250 شخص في احصائيه وزاره الصحه التابعه
للنظام الغير محدثة
منذ 24 ساعه اما في مناطق المعارضه عدد ما
اعتقدوا حياتهم بلغ
2100 شخص اضافه الى ان هناك
6540 جثه 540 جثه وصلت الى معبر باب الهوى
للسوريين قضوا في تركيا وبالتالي هذا
المجموعه الارقام نتحدث عن
3930 سوري قضوا في زلزال البلدين اي في
سوريا وايضا
في سوريا جمعه عن عن ثلاثه الاف في عموم
سوريا طبعا مناطق النظام وحتى المعارضه
يعني
3,350
ونتحدث عن السوريين الذين يعني
قضوا في هذا الزلزال لكن في تركيا نتحدث
عن 540 شخص فبالتالي هنا 3350 في المناطق
السوريه للنظام الخاضع للنظام او للمعارضه
يعني هذه هي الاحصائيه الاجماليه وعدد
الجرحى بالالاف لا يمكن يعني حفر اعداد
الجرحى يعني قبل يومين كنا نتحدث عن 3500
لكن مع وجود قرى فيها جرحى لم يذهب الى
المشافي المشافي لم تتمكن من تسجيل
الاسماء نحن لا يمكن ان نتحدث عن اعداد
الجرحى اللي هي بالتاكيد اكثر من 5000
مصاب بنتيجه الزلزال العدد الاكبر في
جنديرس
1010 اشخاص يعني فقدوا حياتهم في
الزلزالتي المدينه الاكثر تضررا على مستوى
سوريا تليها طبعا مدينه اللاذقيه ثم مدينه
جبله
طيب كذلك ايضا ماذا عن قافلات
المساعدات ايضا او شاحنات المساعدات التي
تدخل عبر
الهواء قبل قليل يعني الناطقه باسم برنامج
الاغذيه العالميه كانت تتحدث عن بطء ربما
في عمليه الدخول عبر هذا المعبر عبر هذا
الطريق نريد وصف لهذه المنطقه جمعه هل تمر
منها القوافل الشاحنات الان بكل سلاسه ام
لا زال الوضع صعبا ما يصعب الامور ايضا
كذلك في الداخل في الشمال الغربي السوري
بالتاكيد يعني المنظمات الدوليه تواجه
صعوبات لان لان تركيا منقوبه وبالتالي
هناك صعوبات لكن هذا لا يخفي حقيقه ان
جميع المعابر معبر باب الهوى باب السلامه
الراعي معابر مفتوحه ولم يتوقف الاعمال
فيها سوى بعض يعني
التباطؤ او العطل بسبب غياب اداره المعابر
من الاطراف
الطرف التركي لانه كما تعلم يعني موظفي
هذه المعابر كانوا يبحثون عن اهلهم بعضهم
قتل حتى في هذا الزلزال لكن خلال اليوم
الثالث كل هذه المعابر تعمل مينا طرفين
بشكل سليم ما يعطل يعني
المنظمات الدوليه التي يجب عليها ادخال
المساعدات فقط من معبر باب الهوى هو تقييم
الاحتياجات على الارض ايضا الحصول على
التمويل ايضا يعني جمع يعني جمع مساعدات
الدول الاعضاء قبل تحويلها وهذا ما يؤثر
عملها في الحقيقه اليوم دخلت 14 شاحنه ضمن
اول قافله امميه الى مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
ويتوقع ان تكون هناك يعني قوافل اخرى سواء
من
منظمات الامم المتحده او حتى من الدول
العربيه التي يترتب يعني السكان في شمال
غرب سوريا ان تدخل ليس فقط يعني مساعدات
انسانيه ايضا يترقبون دخول فرق انقاص
تخصصيه على الاقل تساعدهم في الوصول الى
جتامين من فقدوه تحت ركام كم كبير من
المنازل في عدد كبير من البلدات والمدن في
شمال غرب البلاد
طيب ابقى معنا
الجمعه سنعود اليك في طبعا هذه النشره وفي
سياق هذه النشر لكن حتى اللحظه شكرا جزيلا
لك
وتحول الان الى اسطنبول معي من هناك
الكاتب الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو سيد اوغلو
مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه المباشره على
شاشه العربيه يعني التضرر في المناطق
التركيه هو ضرر كبير لكن يبدو انها يعني
اقل وطئه من من من سوريا في طبعا نتحدث عن
المناطق المدمره او حتى وصول المساعدات
الاغاثيه والانسانيه وغيرها قبل ذلك
الحمله السعوديه الحمله السعوديه حمله
ساهم لاغاثه متضرري زلزال سوريا مشاهدينا
وتركيا تتجاوز 200 مليون ريال حتى الان
الحمله التي اطلقت منذ ثلاثه ايام الحمله
السعوديه حمله ساهم وهي الحمله الشع التي
تعنى باغاثه متضرري زلزال سوريا وتركيا
تتجاوز حتى الان 200 مليون ريال اذا
الحمله التي اطلقتها المملكه العربيه
السعوديه الحمله الشعبيه لاغاثه المتضررين
من الزلزال العنيف والمدمر الذي ضرب سوريا
وتركيا قبل خمسه ايام من الان
طبعا بسبع درجات فاصله سبعه من عشره على
مقياس اختر تجاوزت معه الحمله السعوديه
حمله ساهم اكثر من 200 مليون ريال حتى هذه
اللحظه اذا هذه اخر الاخبار العاجله فيما
يخص اغاثه متضرري الزلزال زلزال سوريا
وتركيا عود الى ضيف فراس رضوان اوغلو سيد
فراس كيف تتعامل السلطات التركيه حتى هذه
اللحظه على مستوى الانقاذ على مستوى
الاغاثات الانسانيه وكذلك الطبيه في
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال المدمر
والعنيف
اولا اريد ان اقول هذا ليس غريبا على
الشعب ارسل هذه المساعدات لهذه الارقام
واكثر من ذلك هذا معروف عن المملكه وشعبها
الكريم بالنسبه
للمتابعات حتى الان
القدمين
لا هدوء لا استراحه طبعا باستثناء المدينه
اورفا
ادعى فيها الباحث لكن باقي المناطق نعم
ما زالت مستمره يعني الناس مترقبه لماذا
يعني قبل قليل يعني كان هناك
خبرا لانقاذ عده اشخاص مثلا احد الاشخاص
لديه كلب يعني ما هو كان في البيت بسبب
صوت هذا الكلب قبل قليل انقاذ هذا الشخص
ويكتبون المعجزه السادسه قبل قليل ايضا تم
انتشال بعض الاشخاص في في هذا في هذا
التوقيت بعد كل هذه الايام يعني ما زال
الامل متبقي في بعض المناطق اظن ان هناك
يعني الانهدام ربما المدمر تماما ربما تقل
فيه نسبه الاحتمالات هناك بعض الابنيه
التي
على بعضها هذا ربما حتى الان يبقى
الاحتمالات وارده به بشكل كبير ربما اخف
في مساله تركيا هي القضيه ان تركيا
امكانيات كبيره جدا لا مقارنه مع سوريا
لذلك كان هناك ربما هذا الشعور لكن هي
حقيقه الامر ان مدن كامله يعني انطاكيا
تعتبر الان مدينه منتهيه تماما في كلها لا
نتكلم عن اجزاء بسيطه فيها غازي عنتاب
فيها
احياء كثيره منتهيه مرعش قبل قليل يعني
نقلتم ايضا على شاشتكم ملاطيا عثمانيه
وحقيقه الكارثه كبيره لكن
هذا الفرق الذي ساعد طبعا تركي على حساب
ربما سوري او الشمال السوري نقول في هذه
القضيه لكن اظن ان مازال هناك بعض الامل
الذي يحدث المنقذين طبعا الكل هنا يتشكر
كل المنقذين من كل العالم الذين جاءوا
الجميع حتى قبل قليل كان لدي صديق صحفي
طالبه مني
ان اصله ببعض الاصدقاء من من يتصلون
بالمنقضين العرب سواء من المملكه او من
دوله الامارات او مقاطع او غيرها يريد ان
يظهر هذا
[موسيقى]
التعاون تحديد الدول الخليج بشكل كبير الى
الى المجتمع التركي عبر الوسائل الاعلاميه
هنا لان كثير من المسائل مشغوله في
فيما يحصل فيها ايضا تعلم انها نتكلم عن
عشر مدن الكثير من الصحفيين والاعلاميين
والتلفزه لديهم اقارب وعائلات في تلك
المدن لذلك يعني هذا واضح ان هناك
شعور على الاقل عند الاعلاميين هنا لان
هذه الدول
تمد يد العونه بشكل كبير طيب ممتاز هل ما
وصل من مساعداتي غثيه وطبيه انسانيه قبل
قليل الزميل عبد المحسن الحربي كان الوصول
الطائره الثالثه من طائرات
الاعانه والاغاثه السعوديه لمركز الملك
سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه هناك
ايضا من ضمن هذه المساعدات مواد ثقيله
واليات ايضا كذلك تساعد في عمليات طبعا
ازاله الركام ازاله الانقاذ ايضا محاوله
يعني العثور على ناجين ربما لو ان الوقت
يعني طويل بعض الشيء منذ هذا الحادث وهذا
الزلزال سيد فراس فما الذي تحتاجه السلطات
التركيه في هذا التوقيت من الدول التي تهب
الى مساعدتها الاولويات التركيه
نعم يعني نحن الان على اعتاب الدخول
للمرحله الثانيه المرحله الاولى كانت هي
فرق الانقاذ كل من ياتي بفرق نقاط كان هذا
بالنسبه لتركيا هو المهم والاهم وطبعا بعد
فرق الانقاذ ضمن المرحله الاولى هو كل شيء
يتعلق سواء
المشافي المتنقله الادويه
السيروم كل ما يتعلق في في هذه الامور
وطبعا بعد ذلك ما يسمى بالايواء الحالي
الالي بطانيات لان الناس كانت في العراق
فلذلك لم يكن تلك لم يكن شيء يعني موجود
خيم لا يوجد شيء سواء انه تم فتح دور
العباده ومراكز الثقافيه والملاعب
واسترجومات الصالات الرياضيه لكن هذا كان
لا يكفي لان الارتباط كبير جدا لذلك انا
اظن
المتطلبات حتى الان يتم ارسال معدات
متطوره معدات ثقيله ايضا لسرعه
يعني ما يسمى
شيل ما يسمى الانقاض ورفعها وايضا نعم
وايضا نقطه ثالثه اظن بعد ذلك ربما هذه
تاتي في المرحله الثانيه كل هذا الدمار
كيف سيتم ترحيله وكيف سيتم التخلص منه
وكيف سيتم يعني اعاده انشاء المدن والمنى
التحتيه هذا كله اظن يعني يحتاج كثير من
الامور لكن الان مازلنا في المرحله الاولى
لذلك المعدات والمعدات الطبيه وربما اطباء
يعني قد يحتاجون ايضا اطباء مساعدين في
تلك المنطقه في كل تلك المناطق ليس يعني
منطقه واحده لان لا ايضا تم نقل الكثير من
الاطباء من كل الولايات تركيا هذا ايضا
ربما يسبب عجن في مدن اخرى لانها لا
تستطيع ايضا ان تقلل عدد الاحتياجات
الطبيه وهناك عجز ايضا تام تقريبا سيد
فراس بالنسبه
الشمال الغربي من سوريا في دخول المساعدات
الاغاثيه الطبيه وربما ايضا حتى الادوات
والاليات الثقيله يعني فبالتالي التركي
كيف تتعامل مع هذا الموقف فيما يخص
المعابر التي من خلالها تستطيع يعني ان
تسهل عمل المنظمات الاغاثيه والانسانيه
برنامج الاغذيه العالمي ايضا حتى قبل قليل
ونتحدث مثلا عن معبر باب الهوى وهو احد
المعابر الرئيسيه المهمه التي يعني اصبحت
الحركه في صعبه بعض الشيء اولا
يعني تضرر الطريق جراء هذا الزلزال او حتى
لكثافه اشعهنات التي تحاول الدخول عبر هذا
المعبر وهو يعني اساسا في اصله غير ربما
صالح بعد هذا الزلزال او صعب يعني وليس
سهل الدخول
هذه مشكله اخرى هذه الامور اللوجستيه
الطرقات والاصول والتنظيم
يعني حقيقه مشكله كبيره يعني ممكن نقول في
اليومين الاولين العلم الاول كان يعني
تخبل كبير هنا في تركيا صدمه لم يكن هناك
تنظيما لكن بعد وصول اليوم الثاني الاصول
المنقذين المساعدات بدايه وصول المساعدات
بدات تتحسن الطرق التنظيم والتخطيط في
تركيا واليوم الثالث وهكذا لكن ما لم يتم
هذا التنظيم بشكل جيد صعب ان تدخل الى الى
شمال السوري بان من يسانده هنا من تركيا
لم يكن موجودا لم يكن مهيا لم يكن مستعدا
لم يكن موجودا حتى لذلك اظن الان كيف
ستسير الامور اتمنى ان تتحسن تحديدا مساله
الطرقات ودخول المعونات والاليات التي
يحتاجونها في اشياء على ذكر هذا الحديث
ايضا هناك مسؤول تركي الان
عبر شاشه العربيه التي نشاهدها على ان
اسفل الشاشه في هذا الشريط الاخباري مسؤول
تركي يقول باننا نناقش فتح معبر ثاني مع
سوريا لادخال المساعدات الدوليه لمناطق
النظام اذا مسؤول تركيا تحدث بانهم
يناقشون فتحه معبر ثاني مع سوريا لادخال
مساعدات الدوليه لمناطق النظام سيد فراس
ابقى معي ساعود اليك مره اخرى
نعيد فقط التذكير بالاخبار العاجله قبل
قليل تركيا تقول بانها تناقش فتح معبر
ثاني مع سوريا لادخال المساعدات الدوليه
لمناطق النظام الحمله الشعبيه السعوديه
ساهم بغاده متضرري زلزال سوريا وتركيا
تجاوزت حتى الان حاجز المئتين مليون ريال
سعودي برنامج الغذاء العالمي قال بانه
ينسق مع جميع الاطراف السوريه للوصول
لمتضرر الزلازل ياتي هذا الحديث بعد ان
قال برنامج الغذاء العالمي بان مخزون
الغذاء في المناطق الشماليه الغربيه
السوريه يكاد ينفذ لم يعد يكفي الا لمئه
الف شخص وربما طبعا لاسبوع واحد الان
مسؤول المسؤول التركي
يعيد طبعا الحديث عن
المعابر يقول بانهم يناقشون فتح معبر بين
هاتاي واللاذقيه لادخال المساعدات لمناطق
النظام هذا طبعا المعبر من المعروف بانه
تابع
لقوات النظام السوري اذا الان تركيا تتحدث
عن نقاش لفتح المعبر بين هاتاي واللاذقيه
لادخال المساعدات لمناطق
النظام السوري اذا افاد مراسل العربيه عن
وصول قافله مساعدات امميه مكونه من اربعه
عشره شاحنه الى معبر باب الهوى على الحدود
بين تركيا وسوريا متجهه للشمال الغربي وهي
اولى القوافل التي تدخل لسوريا بعد خمسه
ايام من حدوث الزلزال
غادرت مطار الملك خالد الدولي الطائره
الاغاثيه الثالثه متوجهه الى مطار اضنه
الدولي في تركيا ضمن الجسر الجوي السعودي
لمساعده ضحايا الزلزال في سوريا وتركيا
والتي حملت على متنها اكثر من اربعه اطنان
من المساعدات الاغاثيه المتنوعه منها
الحقائب الغذائيه والايوائيه والبطانيات
بالاضافه الى المواد الطبيه
واعلنت الحكومه السوريه مناطق حلب
واللاذقيه وحماه وادلب مناطق منكوبه جراء
الدمار الواسع الذي تسبب فيه الزلزال
وبخصوص الخسائر البشريه كان اعلن وزير
الصحه السوري حسن الغباش الخميس ان
الحصيله المؤقته لضحايا الزلزال بلغت
1347 قتيلا
والثاني ومئتان وخمسه وتسعون مصابا
باصابات متفاوته
دعت قمه الاتحاد الاوروبي جميع الاطراف
لتامين وصول المساعدات بسرعه لضحايا
الزلزال في سوريا جاء ذلك في ختام اعمال
القمه الاوروبيه حيث رحبت بمبادره السويد
والمفوضيه الاوروبيه بعقد مؤتمر المانحين
لدعم تركيا وسوريا في مارس المقبل في
بروكسل
ت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه المساعدات
المتعلقه بالزلزال في سوريا من العقوبات
الامريكيه المفروضه على سوريا وذلك حتى
الثامن من اغسطس 2023 وقال نائب وزير
الخزانه اديوال اديمو ان الحديثه يدور على
وجه التحديد عن تحويل الاموال من والى
سوريا مضيفا ان الاستثناءات لا تسمح ببيع
النفط السوري والمنتجات البتروليه في
الولايات المتحده كما انه لا ينطبق على
الاشخاص الذين تعتبروا واشنطن ان
ممتلكاتهم محظوره
ورغم تضاؤل عضوض اخراج ناجين من تحت
الانقاض بمرور خمسه ايام على الزلزال
المدمر لم يفقد الامل الشاب السوري سامر
والذي تطوع في فرق الانقاذ لم يفقد الامل
في العثور على صديقه المفقود تحت انقاض
بلده جنديرس شمال سوريا بعد مرور خمسه
ايام على الزلزال المدمر نتابع
ما حدا بيعرف فينا شيء خالص خالص هنا
بجنديرس شمالي سوريا حيث النصيب الاكبر من
الكارثه المتطوعون من اهالي البلده كان
وحدهم من جابها هولا الزلزال اليومين قبل
انضمام فرق الانقاذ قليله العدد شحيحه
المعدات
طالما عالم ميتين بايدينا بحثنا بايدينا
كريكات
بالعصي بالبواري ايش نلاقي قدامنا نعزل
طالعنا عايشين طلعنا ميتين
ضلينا لثاني يوم لحتى هون
اجى الدفاع المدني اجوا اجوا العالم
تساعدنا في جنديرس قصه البحث عن الناجين
تاخذ معنى اخر
سامر الذي انقذ العشرات منذ اربعه ايام
انهكه التعب لكن انامله لم تتوقف عن البحث
فشخص عزيز عليه تحت هذا الركام رفيق دربه
وابن حارته المدمره ما يزال في عداد
المفقودين اول بنايه وصل عليها البنايه
اللي ساكن فيها رفيقي رفيقي اسمه علي اول
ما وصلت
لا كان في لا دفاع مدني لا كان في شيء
يعني انا لحد الان هذا ثالث يوم رابع يوم
انا هون يعني اهلي ما بعرف عنه غير انه
اوصل بس اشوفه انه عايشين وارجع فقط لا
غير
ضلينا نبحث لحد الان
[تصفيق]
متطوعوه جنديرس لا يحتاجون الى قوائم
المفقودين فهم يعرفون من قضى نحبه ومن
ينتظر وهذا الجهد المتواصل بالنسبه اليهم
هو الواجب اتجاه الاهل والوفاء قبل
التضامن علمنا اعز رفقاتي ابو قلب الطيب
والحنون
يعني ما فينا نقول شيء غير حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل
قدر خربوش العربيه
اعود مره اخرى الى ضيفي من اسطنبول الكاتب
الصحفي فراس رضوان اوغلو مرحبا بك معي مره
اخرى قبل قليل يعني وانا اذكر بهذه
الاخبار
العاجله المسؤول التركي يقول بانهم
يناقشون فتح معبر بين هاتاي واللاذقيه
لادخال المساعدات طبعا لمناطق النظام نريد
الحديث فقط عن هذا المعبر امكانيه ان تدخل
المساعدات ايضا من خلال هذا المعبر هل هو
جاهز ربما لاستقبال مساعدات او شحنات او
قافلات ايضا
للدخول الى المناطق المنكوبه ان كانت
مناطق النظام او حتى وصولا الى مناطق
المعارضه
يعني انا اظن المعابد تقريبا
شبهه جاهزه باستثار الطرقات العالم تماما
في في البعبر الثاني لكن
بعض الطرقات يعني كانت مكسره هل
ممكن ان هل ممكن العدو من عنها لانه
ممكن لكن كان معابر بشكل انها ممكن ان
تعمل لان نحن في حاله استثنائيه ليست في
حالات يعني طبيعيه
ولذلك منذ يومين عندما ايضا سئل الى وزير
الخارجيه التركي قال نفس الشيء نحن ندرس
فتح معبرين وهذا يعني بانه ليس فقط عن
طريق تركيا والمشعارات مع الاخرين
الامريكيه ربما وروسيا وسوريا وغيرهم في
هذا السياق الامم المتحده طبعا
اظن يعني قرارا مشتركا سيكون في هذا
السياق بين الجميع هو تاخر حقيقه الامر
ممكن نعذر المسؤولين الاتراك بسبب الصدمه
لكن
الاخرين ربما تاخروا بسبب الاوضاع
السياسيه في داخل السوري قد يكون ذلك لكن
اصولهم الان حتى وان كان متاخرا لنا نظم
لابد منه لان المنطقه كوبا تحتاج الى ما
بعد النكبه كثير من الاجراءات الاجراءات
الصحيه الطبيه
العمرانيه وغيرها الغذائيه كما تفضلت قبل
قليل بان يعني
المنسوب الغذائي ايضا هناك يعني
ينفذ ولذلك يعني الامور حقيقه يعني سيئه
سنتكلم عن بقعه يا جغرافيه متكامله وكامله
كلها ضربات سواء التي في سوريا او في
تركيا هذه البقعه الجغرافيه يعني هي فيها
كثير من المتشابهات لذلك
المساعدات
الدوليه الان اضافه الى طبعا تركيا ولكن
تركيا
ان تكون لوحدها في هذا السعر من جميع
المستوى العالمي لا بد من على الصعيد
الانقاذي سنتكلم فقط على الصعيد الغذائي
ايضا الجميل والانس سبعه في سوريا وتركيا
اشكرك جزيل الشكر على المشاركه معي في هذه
الساعه
لتغطيه اثار هذا الزلزال الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا من اسطنبول الكاتب الصحفي فراس
رضوان شكرا جزيلا لك
ومعنا من حطاي موفد العربيه عمار الهندي
عمار مرحبا بك معي في هذه التغطيه
المباشره
عمار اريد الصوره من حولك في بهطاي
الكاميرا العربيه اليوم موجوده في غازي
عنتاب في الشمال السوري ايضا وفي كذلك
ايضا حتى مطار غازي عنتاب في اكثر من موقع
واكثر وادمان طبعا وفي اكثر من منطقه في
سوريا وفي تركيا بالنسبه لها طاي كيف هو
الموقف المشهد من حولك حتى اللحظه ما الذي
رصدت عمار
هلا نايف في اللحظه التي تتحدث فيها كانت
اوقفوا جميع الاليات لانهم سمعوا على ما
يبدو صوت احد الناجين تحت الانقاض طلبوا
من الجميع الصمت وبالتالي هنالك امل
تحت هذه البنايه ان يكون هنالك ناجين نحن
هنا نتواجد منذ ساعه هذه نحن في حي مدمر
بالكامل ولا تزال هنالك عائلات تحت هذا
انا اخفض صوتي نايف لانهم طلبوا ذلك
يحاولوا تتبع صوت ياتي من تحت الانقاض
طبعا هنالك العائلات والان سيعني تشاهدها
على الكاميرا تنتظر مصير ذويهم تحت هذه
الانقاض هذا الحي المدمر بالكامل بنايتين
او ثلاث بنايات متلاصقه كانت سقطت بالكامل
انقذوا من انقذوا واخرجوا جثامين قتلى من
تحت الانقاض ولكن هنالك طبعا شاب تركي
التقيته للتو نجا هو من الزلزال خرج يعني
على قيد الحياه فيه بعض الاصابات في وجهه
ولكن شقيقه لا تزال تحت الانقاض وهنالك
عائله ايضا تركيه لديهم شاب وزوجته الحامل
ثمانيه اشهر في بطنها جنين عمره ثمانيه
اشهر في هذه البنايه لا يزال ينتظر حتى
هذه اللحظه
يعني العثور على على هؤلاء الاشخاص
وبالتالي نحن ننتظر هذا الحي طبعا كانت
عمليات الانقاذ لم تبدا فيه سوى يعني صباح
اليوم جاءت عمليات لانه كما تعلم الاحياء
الداخليه لهاتاي او ضواحي هاتاي انطاكيا
في هاتاي لم تدخلها فرق الانقاذ بعد هنالك
احياء كثيره لم تدخلها فرق الانقاذ لهم
يعطون الاولويه للبنيات التي يعتقدون انها
واضح تماما انها فيها ناجين
فيها ناجين انا ساتحدث الان يعني ساحاول
ان اتحدث عبر الشاشه
لاحدى النساء التي تنتظر مصير لو سمحتي
الان في في صوت في امل بوجود ناجين يعني
وانت من لديك هنا ان تذكر لديك ابنتك
الحامل ثمانيه اشهر
وزوجها تحت هذه الانقاذ نعم نعم في المكان
الذي سمعوا فيه صوت صح
اللي بيحاول الدخول اليه
شويه ريحه قلبنا ان شاء الله بده يطلع
رائحه للموت
ما في ريحه تموت ان شاء الله بده يطلعوا
طيبين يا ربي طب ايش شعورك الان بعد ما
سمعوا صوت اشخاص تحت الارض
عربتنا شوي مضايقاك ما
شعرت حينما علمت انه في هنالك صوت صوت
وزوجته الحامل ثمانيه اشهر انا للاسف
انقطع الاتصال لا اسمعك ولكن ساترك
الكاميرا
الان الجميع صامت لانهم يحاولوا تتبع
الصوت داخل هذه البنايه تحت الانقاض
اذا الزميل عمار الهندي ينقل لنا
هو والمصور من منطقه هاتاي عمليات الانقاذ
ويقول بانهم سمعوا قبل قليل ربما صوت
واستغاثه لاحد
طبعا
ضحايا هذا الزلزال الموجودين تحت ركام
الانقاض وطبعا هناك حاله من الصمت ربما
المطبق واخفاض الاصوات
لسماع صوته وتحديد مكانه بطريقه يعني
اكيده
لمحاوله اخراجه ايضا من تحت كومه
الانقاض وهذا المبنى الذي دمر
ويعني سقط بشكل كامل نشاهد طبعا الجرافات
الاليات ايضا الثقيله وهي تحيط بالمكان
المسعفين والمنقذين ايضا وكذلك الفرق
المتخصصه ربما في اخراج يعني المتضررين او
القتلى او المصابين ايضا من تحت الركام في
كل الاحوال انا اشكر الزميل عمار الهندي
على هذه الصوره التي نقلها الينا من منطقه
هاتاي ولا زلنا نتابعها معكم الان على
الشاشه
اذا اظهرت صوره صناعيه حجم الدمار الذي
خلفها الزلزال في جنوب تركيا تلك الصور
وشملت مستشفيات وصوامع حبوب ومبان اخرى
منهاره نشاهد
[موسيقى]
في مدينه حلب السوريه فقد شاب سوري عائلته
في غضون ثوان معدوده على حد وصفه متاثرين
بتراكم خطوط او بتراكمي حطام المباني
المنهاره جراء الزلزال المدمر المشاهد
[موسيقى]
عيلتي اهلي كلهم روحي
اهلي كلهم راحوا ابوي وامي
واخوي واختي وابن اختي ما عم بصدق ما بصدق
يا جماعه ما بصدق
[موسيقى]
وهذه طبعا بعض الاخبار غير متعلقه
بالزلزال حيث اكد الجيش الاوكراني في
بيانه اليومي ان القوات الروسيه كثفت من
هجماتها الجويه على مناطق واسعه شرق
اوكرانيا تمهيدا لهجوم برين واسع في
الذكرى الاولى لاندلاع الحرب واضاف بيان
الجيش الاوكراني ان مدينه خاركيف تعرضت
لقصف كثيف ليله البارحه بما اكد عمده
زبروج ان تولي ان المدينه تتعرضت للقصف
سبعه عشره مره خلال ساعه واحده في محاوله
الروسيه لاخماد الدفاعات الاوكرانيه قبل
تنفيذ هجوم شامل على الشرق الاوكراني
قال وزير الخارجيه الروسي ان دعوات الى
تفتيت روسيا تتزايد في الغرب مشددا على
وقوف موسكو بحزم والمواجهه بمستوى اقل
لافروف اكد ايضا سعيا بلاده لتشكيل نظام
متعدد الاقطاب لخلق ظروف خارجيه متساويه
للتنميه الشامله وذلك في الوقت الذي
تتزايد به المحاولات للسيطره على القضايا
الدوليه والعلاقات الاقتصاديه بشكل كامل
على حد قوله
قال مدوب روسيا الدائم لدى الامم المتحده
فسيلي نيبالزيا ان الشروط التي طرحتها في
مبادره السلام غير مقبوله واضاف المندوب
الروسي ان كل المبادرات سواء كانت في صيغه
السلام او قمه السلام هي قذائف فارغه
واضحه تهدف فقط الى التاثير
الدعائي وفق تعبير معتبرا انه ومن الواضح
ان الشروط المنصوص عليها فيها غير مقبوله
اعلن القائد العمل للقوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه الجنرال فاليري زالوجوني عن
اطلاق روسيا صاروخين من طراز كاليبر كروز
من البحر الاسود حيث اخترقت الصواريخ
الروسيه المجال الجوي لدولتي مولودوفا
ورومانيا قبل وصولها لاوكرانيا
طلبت الخارجيه الصينيه بان تتحمل الولايات
المتحده المسؤوليه اذا اثبتت وقوفها وراء
تقريبي خطي انابيب الغاز
في سبتمبر الماضي الخارجيه الصينيه اعتبرت
ان تلك الانفجارات اثرت بشكل سلبي للغايه
على البيئه وسوق الطاقه العالميتين
تصريحات الخارجيه الصينيه جاءت تعليقا على
تقرير للصحف الامريكي سيمور هيرش بان
واشنطن وبمساعده اوسلو فجرت خطوطه انابيب
الغاز التي تربط روسيا بالمانيا تحت بحر
البلطيق رفضت واشنطن المقال ووصفت
المعلومات بانها محض خيال كما نفتان
نرويجيه تورط لها في الحادث
نستمر معكم في هذه التغطيه لكن الان مع
الزميله حنين الشوري وفي استديوهات
العربيه من دبي اليك حنين